[Music]
Princess Diana was regal she was warm
she was the people's princess but to her
two sons William and Harry she was on
mum she stood as a mum I would say that
she's you know best mom in the world
we're taking a royal plunge into what
princess die was like as a parent and
how her mom life came to be
[Music]
Diana was only 20 when she married a
vendor T two-year-old Prince Charles and
as the saying goes first comes love then
comes marriage then comes William in the
baby carriage
well the prince and princess of wales
may have had the whole love thing a
little backwards everything else in
their relationship lined up royal
couples tend to have a baby within the
first year Prince Charles and Princess
Diana gave birth to William within the
11 months of marriage you see Charles
being the future King and all was
expected to marry a virgin which kind of
explains Charles and Di's age difference
and their rush to procreate
[Music]
Diana's purity actually garnered
worldwide interest and get this her
uncle even confirmed it to the Daily
Star telling the outlet quote Diana I
can assure you has never had a lover
what now died initially shied away from
the press but British journalist and TV
producer Paul Rainey told ET she took a
different approach once she was with
child
Diana was very open with her pregnancy
with the press almost in a way to
diminish the further the world quickly
fell in love with Diana and her
pregnancy fashion wench back in the
early 80s was slightly baggy er than
what we've seen a pregnant Kate and now
Megan sport the princess garnered even
more admiration when she became a mom
she brought affection and warmth to her
family and she wasn't afraid to show it
she gave birth to William on June 21st
in 1982 and welcomed Harry two years
later on September 15th we thought you
know incredibly loved her Knight
she always understood that there was a
real life outside of palace walls she
set us up really well she gave us the
right tools the Princess of Wales made
sure young Harry was center stage at the
world practice for Diana taught the boys
how to navigate life as Royals but most
importantly made sure they always felt
loved
something William and Harry opened up
about in the 2017 HBO documentary Diana
our mother she was just engulfed you and
and squeezed you as tight as possible
and is a bit of a royal rebel she made
sure her sons enjoyed their childhood my
mother cherish those moments of of
privacy and being able to be that mother
rather than the Princess of Wales our
mother was a total kid through and
through she would come and watch us play
football and you know smuggle sweets
into our socks and I mean like literally
walking back from a football match and
having sort of five packets of
starbursts and just the whole shirt was
just bulging with sweets she was one of
the naughtiest parents Diana also
encouraged William and Harry to be
charitable early on she first took well
to a homeless shelter when he was only 7
she very much wanted to take us away
from that sort of the royal aspect of
life if you like and get us to see the
rawness of life it's something both
William and Harry practice to this day
as they work to keep Diana's legacy
alive we will do everything we can to
make sure that she's never forgotten and
I hope that a lot of my mother's talents
are shown in a lot of the work that I do
[Music]